FOR DOUBLE MASKING, DESPITE
BEING VACCINATED.
>> YOU’RE TELLING EVERYBODY TO
WEAR A MASK, WHETHER THEY’VE HAD
AN INFECTION OR  A VACCINE.
IF WE’RE NOT SPREADING THE
INFECTION ISN’T IT JUST
THEATRE?
>> NO IT’S NOT.
>> YOU’VE HAD THE VACCINE AND
YOU’RE WEARING TWO MASKS ISN’T
THAT THEATRE?
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN WITH THE
THEATRE.
>> WHAT PROOF IS THERE THAT
THERE’S SIGNIFICANT REINFECTIONS
WITH HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATH
FROM THE VARIANCE?
NONE IN OUR COUNTRY, ZERO.
AINSLEY: SO THAT WAS A SENATE
COMMITTEE HEARING AND SENATOR
RAND PAUL JOINS US TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT WENT DOWN AND WHAT HAPPENED
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
AINSLEY: YOU’RE WELCOME, TO
SENATOR, SET THAT UP FOR THE
AUDIENCE AT HOME.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> SO WE’VE HAD 90 MILLION
VACCINES IN OUR COUNTRY ABOUT
50 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED.
WE’VE GOT ANOTHER 30 MILLION
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GOTTEN THE
DISEASE NATURALLY LIKE I
HAVE AND THE QUESTION IS DO THEY
HAVE IMMUNITY BUT WE’VE ALWAYS
BELIEVED THAT.
THAT’S THE SCIENCE OF VACCINES
IS THAT WHEN YOU GET AN
INFECTION OR  YOU GET THE
VACCINATION YOU DEVELOP
IMMUNITY AND YET HE’S MOVING THE
GOAL POST AND SAYING WELL,
YOU MIGHT GET THIS VARIANT FROM
SOUTH AFRICA AND MY POINT TO HIM
IS SHOW US THE EVIDENCE.
SHOW US THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALREADY HAD
COVID OR  PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ALREADY HAD THE VACCINE ARE
GETTING IT AGAIN.
IF THEY’RE GETTING IT IN LARGE
NUMBERS AND GETTING ILL AND
GOING TO THE HOSPITAL AND DYING
WE SHOULD KNOW THAT, BUT IT’S
NOT TRUE.
IT’S HIS CONJECTURE.
HE SAYS WE MIGHT GET IT,
THEREFORE WE NEED TO WEAR THE
MASK FOR ANOTHER YEAR.
STEVE: YEAH.
>> THIS IS EQUIVALENT OF SAYING
WELL WE MIGHT GET THE SPANISH
FLU SO MAYBE WE SHOULD WEAR THE
MASK UNTIL THE SPANISH FLU
COMES BACK.
IT’S A RIDICULOUS NOTION NOT
BASED ON SCIENCE, AND WHAT HE IS
DOING IS THEATRE AND IT GOES
AGAINST THE SCIENCE OF VACCINES.
DR. FAUCI HAS IMMUNITY.
HE CAN’T GET IT AGAIN, BUT HE’S
WEARING A MASK BECAUSE IT’S ONE
OF HIS NOBEL LIES TO CONVINCE
EVERYBODY TO WEAR MASKS, BUT
IT’S NOT TRUE.
IF YOU’VE BEEN VACCINATED YOU
DON’T NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
STEVE: SO THAT’S REALLY YOUR
MESSAGE IS ONCE YOU’RE
VACCINATED, YOU DON’T NEED TO
WEAR A MASK AROUND OTHER PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ALSO BEEN VACCINATED
WHICH IS A GREAT SALES PITCH FOR
EVERYBODY GETTING THE SHOT.
>> RIGHT, EXACTLY.
I’M NOT AGAINST THE VACCINE.
I’M FOR PEOPLE BEING VACCINATED,
IN FACT THAT’S HOW WE’RE GETTING
OUT OF THIS , BOTH NATURAL
IMMUNITY, HAVING HAD THE
INFECTION, PLUS THOSE BEING
VACCINATED IS GOOD, BUT ONCE YOU
ARE VACCINATED, YOU’RE TWO WEEKS
OUT FROM THE SECOND DOSE, YOU
ARE SAFE, AND THERE’S NO RECORD
SO FAR OF ANYBODY BEING
HOSPITALIZED OR  DYING THAT’S
BEEN VACCINATED.
THERE’S ALSO NO RECORD OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE GOTTEN IN NATURALLY
BEING REINFECTED AND BEING
HOSPITALIZED OR  DYING, SO WHAT
WE HAVE IS THAT IT’S VERY VERY
SAFE ONCE YOU’VE HAD THE VACCINE
, VERY VERY SAFE ONCE
YOU’VE HAD THE INFECTION AND WE
SHOULD BE GETTING THAT REWARD.
IN FACT IT SHOULD BE INCENTIVE
TO PEOPLE TO GO OUT AND GET
VACCINATED BUT DR. FAUCI
GETS THIS UPSIDE DOWN AND HE’S
SUCH A GOVERNMENT WORRY WATTER
THAT HE SAYS WELL YOU MIGHT GET
SOME DAY.
WELL WE MIGHT GET ANYTHING.
WE MIGHT GET THE SPANISH FLU
AGAIN BUT THAT’S NOT THE WAY
SCIENCE WORKS.
HE NEEDS TO SHOW US EVIDENCE AS
TO WHY.
IT’S INCUMBENT UPON HIM TO PROVE
TO US THAT WE NEED TO WEAR A
MASK, NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
PETE: IT’S A GREAT POINT,
SENATOR BY WHAT STANDARD ON THE
SAME POINT BY WHAT STANDARD
DO YOU BELIEVE DR. FAUCI OR
OTHERS AS YOU PUT IT,
GOVERNMENT WORRY WARTS WOULD
FAVEOLI SAY TAKE THE MASK OFF?
WHAT IS THAT THRESHOLD OTHER
THAN WHAT HE’S ALREADY SAID?
>> THAT’S GREAT BECAUSE I THINK
IT LEADS TO THE ANSWER BEING
NEVER, BECAUSE THERE’S
ULTIMATELY ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE THERE SO HE’S SAYING
THE SOUTH AFRICAN VARIANT MIGHT
COME.
I’M SAYING TO HIM, SHOW ME THAT
THE SOUTH AFRICAN VARIANT IS
INFECTING PEOPLE, CAUSING THEM
TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL, AND
CAUSING THEM TO DIE IN
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS.
IF IT’S A SIGNIFICANT PATHOGEN,
I’LL LISTEN, BUT THE THING IS IS
MOST OF THE THINGS WE’RE FINDING
OUT OF THE OPPOSITE THEN THE
VACCINE ACTUALLY WORKED ON
ALL OF THE VARIANTS SO FAR AND
THAT THERE ISN’T MASSIVE DEATH
AND REHOSPITALIZATION FROM
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
THIS IS GOOD NEWS.
INSTEAD OF SAYING IT MIGHT
HAPPEN, HE NEEDS TO SHOW ME A
SCIENTIFIC STUDY SHOWING THAT IT
IS HAPPENING, BECAUSE I’M NOT
ONE TO WEAR A MASK FOR THE REST
OF MY LIFE FOR SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN, UNLESS YOU SHOW ME
THAT IT ACTUALLY IS HAPPENING,
SO THE SCIENCE, THE BURDEN OF
PROOF SHOULD BE ON THERE’S.
THEY SHOULDN’T GET TO SAY OH,
WEAR A MASK BECAUSE DR. FAUCI
LIKES WEARING A MASK AND THE
WHOLE DOUBLE MASK IS
COMPLETE THEATRE.
THERE’S NO SCIENCE SAYING THAT
HE CAN GET REINFECTED.
THERE ARE NO STUDIES SHOWING RE
INFECTION AFTER VACCINE.
STEVE: BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR
YOU’RE TALKING, YOU KNOW, HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT AFTER THE VACCINE.
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT HAD THE
VACCINE, AND HAVE NOT HAD
COVID AND DON’T HAVE THE
IMMUNITIES IN THEIR SYSTEM,
THOSE PEOPLE SHOULD WEAR A MASK,
WHEN THEY CANNOT SOCIAL SOCIAL
DISTANCE.
>> I THINK IT DEPENDS ON THE
RISK FACTORS.
IF THEY’RE A KID THE RISK FACTOR
OF GETTING THIS AND DYING IS
VIRTUALLY ZERO SO I’M NOT A BIG
FAN OF HAVING KIDS WEAR MASKS.
I THINK IT’S TO EACH HIS OWN.
IF YOU WANT TO SEND A KID TO A
SCHOOL THAT THEY SAY WEAR MASK
DO IT, SEND YOUR KID TO A
PRIVATE SCHOOL AND THEY DON’T
WEAR A MASK THAT’S ALSO FINE.
THE RISK FACTORS ARE THINGS
INDIVIDUALS IN A FREE SOCIETY
SHOULD DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MASK MANDATES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY, THE
INCIDENCE OF THE DISEASE
WENT UP, PARTICULARLY IN
DECEMBER AND JANUARY, AS WE WENT
UP EXPONENTIALLY, IT’S A RISE IN
INFECTIONS OCCURRED EVERYBODY
WAS WEARING MASKS SO THERE’S NOT
A GREAT DEAL OF EVIDENCE THAT
MASK MANDATES OR  ECONOMIC
LOCKDOWNS HAVE CHANGED THE
TRAJECTORY.
THE ONLY THING THAT’S CHANGING
THE TRAJECTORY IS THE VACCINE,
SO THAT’S WHY I DON’T THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD BE TRICKED INTO
THINKING THE MASK IS THE ANSWER,
THE VACCINE ACTUALLY IS THE
ANSWER, BUT THE MASK REALLY
ISN’T AN ANSWER.
WE’VE HAD RAMPANT INFECTION WITH
EVERYBODY WEARING MASK.
MOST PEOPLE GETTING INFECTIONS
SAY THEY’VE BEEN WEARING THE
MASK.
THE CLOTH MASKS DON’T REALLY
WORK AT ALL SO THE MASKS HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO WORK IN HOSPITAL
SETTINGS BUT NONE OF THE MASKS
HAVE REALLY BEEN PROVEN TO WORK.
AINSLEY: HOW DO YOU THINK THIS
IS GOING TO PLAY OUT, LET’S
SAY, IN A FEW MORE MONTHS
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW NO ONE IS
HUGGING PEOPLE ARE SOCIALLY
DISTANCED, WEARING THE MASK,
PEOPLE ARE STAYING IN THEIR OWN
SPACE, DO YOU THINK WE’LL REMAIN
LIKE THAT AS A COUNTRY OR  WE GO
BACK TO THE WAY IT WAS?
>> ULTIMATELY THE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRATS LIKE FAUCI WILL LOSE
PEOPLE ARE ALREADY PUSHING BACK.
LOOK, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SAYING
ON JULY 4, YOU CAN GET TOGETHER
AND PEOPLE ARE ALREADY DOING
WHAT THEY WANT.
IT’S A FREE COUNTRY AND THEY ARE
GETTING TIRED OF THESE PEOPLE.
LOOK HOW MANY PEOPLE ALL THE
TIME IN THEIR 70S HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED, GET THE TWINKLE BACK
IN THEIR EYE, GOING TO
RESTAURANTS, THEY REALLY DON’T
CARE WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN OR   F
AUC I’M OR  ANY OF THE
SO-CALLED PEOPLE ARE SAYING
THEY FEEL SAFE AFTER THE VACCINE
AND THAT’S WHAT THEY SHOULD AND
IF THE SCIENCE SAYS YOU’RE SAFE
AFTER THE VACCINE, WHAT A
TERRIBLE SELLING MESSAGE, IF
THAT’S TRUE, THEY CAN GO AHEAD
AND TRY TO SAY THAT, BUT THEY
ARE TRYING TO TELL YOU THE
VACCINE IS SAFE AND WORKING
AND YET YOU STILL HAVE TO WEAR A
MASK.
THAT’S A CONTRADICTORY
PROPOSITION.
STEVE: SENATOR WHILE WE GOT YOU
HERE YESTERDAY THE HOUSE PASSED
TWO IMMIGRATION BILLS.
THEY ESSENTIALLY PASSED THE SAME
THINGS TWO YEARS AGO.
NOW THEY HEAD TO THE SENATE.
IS THERE ANYWAY THEY GET 10
REPUBLICAN SENATORS TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT?
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE GOT A GREAT
IDEA ON HOW TO PROVIDE PERMANENT
CITIZENSHIP FOR THESE DREAMERS
AND ALSO FARM WORKERS.
>> YOU KNOW, THEY WANTED TO
ACTUALLY TALK TO US I HAVEN’T
HAD ANY OF THEM TALK TO ME, AND
THEY WON’T GET ON THE ELEVATOR,
AND IT’S RIDICULOUS, BECAUSE IT
GO AGAINST ALL OF THE SCIENCE,
BUT THEY STILL HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED AND YET THEY STILL
LITERALLY, I THINK THEY FEAR
HAVING THEIR PICTURE TAKEN WITH
ME.
STEVE: THAT COULD BE IT.
PETE: [LAUGHTER]
>> BUT HERE IS THE THING WITH
IMMIGRATION.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS TO HAVE A
RULE AT THE BORDER WHERE WE SEND
THOSE BACK AND THOSE REMAIN IN
MEXICO AND YOU CAN’T HAVE ANY
KIND OF FORGIVENESS PLAN ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
FORGIVE THE 3 MILLION PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY HERE ILLEGALLY
WHAT DOES THAT TELL TO THE OTHER
MILLIONS MARCHING UP THROUGH
CENTRAL AMERICA?
STEVE: SENATOR WE’RE HAVING A